ماذا عن أولئك الذين يقولون
إنك في الأشهر الأخيرة
نحيف للغاية ،
لطالما كنت نحيف البشرة ، لقد كنت
رقيقًا منذ اليوم الأول عندما
يقول الناس شيئًا كاذبًا ، فأنا أهاجم هؤلاء
الأشخاص
لأن الأخبار تتلاشى  مع قتل
وسائل الإعلام الإخبارية
يفلتون من القتل ،
إنه أمر صعب للغاية من حيث قوانين التشهير
لأن وسائل الإعلام محمية
للغاية ومن السخف أنهم
محميون للغاية ولكن يمكنهم كتابة
أي شيء تقريبًا ،
والفرق معي على الأقل يدفعون بعض الثمن
وأعتقد أن المزيد من الأشخاص يجب أن يكون لديهم هذا
الموقف وأعتقد أنك ستجد تقارير
أكثر دقة
بما في ذلك ما هو
غير دقيق حتى الآن أعتقد أن
سلوكك غير دقيق أعتقد أن
الأسئلة التي
كنت تطرحها على الأشخاص في
مؤسستي كانت
غير دقيقة  والأسئلة الخاطئة وغير العادلة
بحكم تعريفها لا يمكن أن تكون
غير دقيقة ، فهي مشكوك فيها أعتقد
أنني أعتقد أن الأسئلة نفسها قد
طُرحت
بطريقة جعلت منها عبارات وهي
كذلك  جاءت العبارات مقابل
الأسئلة وأعتقد أن هذا ليس
تقريرًا جيدًا مثل
لا يهم ، أعني لا
أعتقد أن مشاهديك سيكونون
مهتمين جدًا بها ولا
أريد أن أحرجك  أعتقد أنني سأكون فاتورة
، فلنتحدث عن أه ما تحدثنا عنه
بالأمس
أولئك في المجتمع المالي الذي
أتحدث عنه وتحدثنا عن هذا
على الهاتف
أه من قال وهم يقولون
هذا ليس أنا
أه هؤلاء هم ماذا  هل تقصد بهم
هذا شخص أو شخصان وماذا
عن الأشخاص الإيجابيين خمسة أو ستة
لكن أولئك الذين قالوا
أشياء سلبية وهنا
نعود إلى الخلف إلى السلبية والعودة إلى
السلبية إلى أن تعرف ماذا تفعل
قمت
بإجراء هذه المقابلة مع شخص آخر
لكننا تحدثنا عن هذا بالأمس على
الهاتف ، هذا هو بالضبط ما تحدثت
إليه في المقابلة مع شخص آخر ،
حقًا ، لا تحتاج إلى ذلك ، افعل ذلك
مع شخص
آخر استمتع بوقتك لأنك بصراحة
رجل سلبي جدا
و  أه أعتقد أنه من الظلم جدًا
الإبلاغ عن حظ سعيد ،
فأنا لا أتفق معك ، آسف لأنك تشعر بهذه
الطريقة
لا يوجد شيء لم
نناقشه على الهاتف.